remaking a classic movie is never easy
you've got to appeal to fans of the
original wall impressing a whole new
crop of critics and drawing in new fans
at the same time it's a tough balancing
act and it's easy to screw up in the
1971 british crime film Get Carter
London gangster Jack Carter returns to
his home town after the death of his
brother when he suspects foul play he
decides to dig deeper and find out who
was really responsible as he delves back
into the city's world of organized crime
tensions escalate and violent conflict
it suits the 2000 remake of Get Carter
starring Sylvester Stallone wasn't
exactly a bright spot in the actors
career this time the story was set in
America with Carter a mob enforcer
living in Las Vegas who returns home to
Seattle after his brother's death but it
wasn't the change in setting that
disappointed critics it was the fact
that the plot was formulaic and
contrived in comparison to the original
despite the fact that it was supposed to
be a suspenseful mystery Entertainment
Weekly's Owen gleiberman wrote Carter
who goes to Seattle to hunt down his
brother's killer may have entered a
labyrinth of evil but his response to it
is as hollow as it is monolithic 1990s
Total Recall follows Douglas Quaid a
construction worker who begins having
disturbing dreams about life on Mars he
ends up getting a memory chip implanted
that gives him a virtual reality
experience of working as a secret agent
on the planet but as the film goes on
the line between fact and fiction
becomes blurred and Quaid struggles to
figure out who he really is
and what he has really done on Mars if
I'm with me who the hell am i here's
where the 2012 remake went completely
wrong it isn't even set on Mars instead
it takes place on a future dystopian
earth and sure that concept could have
worked well anyway but this version of
Total Recall fell flat in pretty much
every other aspect too
who the hell am i according to some
critics the action sequences were the
only real bright spot of the pill sin
abuse Joseph Walsh wrote whilst the
action is grand in scope and certainly
high in production values it somehow
lacks any tangible sense of tension or
drama in John Carpenter's 1980 cult
classic the fog a mysterious fog covers
a California town bringing with it the
ghosts of dead sailors who promptly said
about terrorizing the residents the
concept could have been corny but the
film's slow billed to its scarier
moments kept audiences hooked it seemed
like a film that could have benefited
from a remake with updated special
effects - sadly the 2005 remake managed
to botch it completely
although Carpenter produced the remake
himself it just didn't strike a chord
with critics the scares weren't scary
and the ghosts didn't come across as
threatening or intimidating in any way
and if a horror film isn't genuinely
scary it usually ends up feeling boring
and muddled which is exactly what
happened here
writing for screen crush critic matt
singer suggested it could be one of the
worst movies ever made he wrote this
movie is not even that foggy the clouds
and two-thirds of this movie are so
sparse they wouldn't even warrant a push
notification from your phone's weather
app The Stepfather is a 1987 slasher
about a murderer who kills his family
changes his identity and then marries
into another family so he can repeat the
process his new stepdaughter soon
becomes suspicious of him and sets out
to prove his identity and save her
family the film falls somewhere between
horror crime thriller and black comedy
and the plot is just interesting enough
to carry audiences along to a genuinely
satisfying conclusion but the 2009
remake of The Stepfather failed to do
the same
the originals palatable tension just
isn't there the plot holes are
distracting then the climax of the film
ties up everything a little too neatly
with a predictable series of events
leading up to the final moments for The
AV Club Scott Tobias wrote even by
horror remake standards The Stepfather
sets the bar for pointlessness
originally released in 1956 around the
world in 80 days is an epic adventure
based on the novel of the same name by
Jules Byrne one that ended up winning
five Academy Awards including the Award
for Best Picture the plot is pretty
simple Phileas Fogg makes a bet that he
can get around the world in
eighty days and subsequently sets off on
a race around the globe a tale like this
might seem timeless but the 2004 remake
didn't take audiences on quite the same
ride as the original instead it barely
followed the plot of ferns novel and
ended up being nominated for worst
remake of the Razzies it also went on to
win most unwelcome remake of the
stinkers bad movie awards Marty maps
summed it up for movie habit when he
wrote around the world in 80 days is the
kind of movie you should see if you're
looking for an excuse to sit in an
air-conditioned theater for two hours
and you've already seen all the good
movies Nicolas Cage has a strong track
record of starring in films that proved
a little underwhelming for critics and
Bangkok dangerous definitely falls into
that category
the original Bangkok dangerous is a Thai
crime thriller about Kong a gunman who
can neither hear nor speak he works as
an assassin for hire struggles to find
real meaning in life and eventually
meets a tragic end it's an intense film
packed full of action and emotion JJ's
version however couldn't hold a candle
to the original despite the fact that it
was made by the same directors in the
2008 remake of Bangkok dangerous several
key details were changed cage plays the
protagonist Joe who isn't deaf or mute
the cinematography is visually confusing
at times and the idea of a hitman who
eventually gains a conscience feels kind
of cliche as Scott Nash remarked in a
review for three movie buffs the
burnt-out assassin stick is old and
tired
the 1959 historical drama Ben Hur is an
undisputed classic interestingly enough
this version of Ben Hur was actually a
remake itself and one which definitely
improved on the original 1925 silent
film Ben Hur a tale of Christ for one
thing it features Hollywood's most
iconic chariot race it was difficult to
see how a remake could have outdone the
1959 version that didn't stop paramount
from trying well I could have been a
studying historical epic turned out to
be a box office bomb the aesthetics were
downgraded by haphazard editing and
lackluster CGI and aside from a few
exciting action scenes little about the
film stood out
Alison Rohit wrote in The Herald a
thrill ride in parts as long as you can
forgive the ho keenest wouldn't dialogue
and long slog running time
19:56 invasion of the body snatchers
might not seem as slick or prettiest
today's horror films but it's still
widely regarded as a classic in this
sci-fi horror movie alien spores grow
into seed pods that can produce physical
replacements of human beings without any
shred of human emotions a critically and
commercially successful remake followed
in 1978 and another retelling titled
Body Snatchers was released in 1993 in
2007 another version of the story was
released this time titled the invasion
rather than creating a straight remake
the writers tried to take it in a
different direction and make the story
more contemporary and political the
result a film that was widely criticized
for an inconsistent narrative one whose
deeper themes were subsequently lost in
the mess for slate Dana Stevens wrote it
falls far short is an effective sci-fi
thriller not to mention the brainy
political allegory it's determined to be
1953 s House of Wax was a 3d for hits in
which a sculptor stalks his museum by
killing people and coding their corpses
with wax it was actually a remake of an
earlier film the 1933 mystery of the wax
museum audiences were mostly
enthusiastic about this version and it
did fairly well at the box office all in
all not a bad go in 2005 a modern-day
House of Wax was released but the plot
was quite different preferring to err
more on the shrill teen slasher side of
things now there's nothing wrong with
the cheesy slasher but compared to the
impact of the 1953 version this
retelling was shallow and way too
reliant on cheap scares granted this was
probably obvious based on the casting
alone with Paris Hilton in a supporting
role it was never going to be taking
home an Oscar as Maitland McDonough
wrote for TV Guide it delivers some
bracingly nasty gore scenes but there's
no spark left in the run scream repeat
formula in the 1991 film Point Break
Keanu Reeves plays an undercover FBI
agent who has to investigate an
infiltrate a group of bank robbers who
also happen to be surfers but while the
premise of Point Break may have seemed
clunky everything still managed to come
together to make a downright ridiculous
yet genuinely entertaining movie
so how do you recapture the magic of a
film with an unexpected cult following
well at the movies 2015 remake is any
indication you can't the 2015 Point
Break features some visually stunning
action scenes but other than that it
totally falls flat in a review for Times
of India Regan Gavin rush kina summed up
the film's fatal flaw Point Break comes
across as a string of admittedly amazing
action sequences and sports feats with
the rest of the film haphazardly built
up around it
the 1985 zombie film Day of the Dead
follows a group of scientists and
soldiers who live in a bunker in the
aftermath of a zombie invasion several
zombies are kept captive for the purpose
of research and arrangement that
obviously goes very wrong indeed before
long a conflict breaks out that
threatens the very survival of the human
race
now Day of the Dead is obviously a
pretty bloody film but as with all
George Romero zombie films it balances
its violence with a genuinely thoughtful
critique of society however the 2008
remake forsakes any attempt to bring a
real message to the audience in favor of
gore and guts there's no real commentary
on the state of humanity the special
effects look cheap and the zombies are
so intelligent and agile that they
operate less like zombies and more like
evil human beings with superpowers
writing for the pittsburgh city paper
jordan Snowden said like infected zombie
areas put under quarantine I would like
this film away in a box and leave it
there for good Adam Sandler's 2002
remake of Frank Capra's 1936 bill mr.
deeds goes to town doesn't exactly rank
among his best work in the original
Longfellow deeds gets by making a living
by juggling odd jobs during the Great
Depression until he suddenly inherits 20
million dollars from his late uncle he
soon falls in love with Louise bate
Bennett and an unexpected love story
unfolds the plot of 2002 s mr. deeds is
similar but the jokes are grating the
characters of bland and irritating and
the entire narrative is dumbed down to
the point where it's practically
insulting to the audience and a Capra's
memory in a review for the Seattle Times
Moira MacDonald wrote mr. deeds is
supposed to be a celebration of the
goodness of regular people but really
it's nothing more than a moneymaker for
the filmmakers and appointments star
vehicle for Sandler 1972's the
Heartbreak Kid is a different kind of
romance
- comedy self-absorbed Lenny is married
to clingy Lila and on their honeymoon he
ditches her to pursue a manipulative
college girl named Kelly he impulsively
divorces Lila and proposes to Kelly but
it becomes clear that her sole reason
for marrying him is to rebel against her
father at their wedding Lenny ends up
ignored by almost everyone including the
bride and this dark comedy ends on a
fairly depressing note the 2007 remake
of the Heartbreak Kid starring Ben
Stiller didn't do quite so much to push
the boundaries of the genre the
characters are nasty to the point -
being practically irredeemable and the
whole thing totally fails to
differentiate itself from any other film
in the genre in fact Rolling Stone
dubbed it the worst remake of the year
in a review for a film critic Peter sub
Chen Sookie said The Heartbreak Kid is
an ugly hateful and deeply unfunny bit
of hackwork remake in a truly classic
horror film is no easy task in the 1998
remake of psycho made that crystal clear
it certainly didn't help that the
original 1960 psycho was downright
chilling and near-perfect so fans
weren't exactly begging for a do-over
either we all go a little mad sometimes
the remake didn't take much artistic
license opting instead for a
shot-for-shot copy of the original
honestly it's hard not to ask why it was
worth making the film in the first place
if the filmmakers would refuse to
deviate from the source material
everything from the dialog to the score
is almost a carbon copy of the original
somehow though they still got it wrong
the film was nominated for a grand total
of three Golden Raspberry Awards and one
for worst remake and worst director
nitrate online reviews Sean axe maker
wrote even with Hitchcock shot list Van
Sant can't come up with anything more
than a wand tribute to the master
proving it takes more than a good
storyboard to make a film work in 2006
the Japanese horror film Cairo was
remade for American audiences as pulse
in Cairo evil spirits managed to find
their way into our world through the
internet causing a series of strange and
horrifying events to occur the film
features two parallel narratives that
show characters dealing with the
consequences of this paranormal invasion
in the remake the unique dual narrative
approach was scrapped the premise was
similar enough but everything that made
the original a cult favorite in Japan
was missing the film relies on grotesque
imagery to get its points across but
cheap thrills aren't enough for a film
that fails to delve deeper into any
meaningful themes frightening for the
Austin Chronicle critic marks a blog
said the remake is a curiously dull
Americanization of one of the finest
examples of subtle moody j-horror out
there the 1980 film Fame follows a group
of high-school students after they gain
acceptance to the prestigious High
School of Performing Arts in New York
City as they study their respective
crafts they face difficult obstacles in
the classroom onstage and in their
personal lives there are moments that
slip into melodrama but overall the
characters are relatable and sympathetic
and the musical numbers were a hit but
the 2009 remake of Fame just doesn't
strike that same atmosphere it's too
slick and polished like it was intended
to be an after-school special rather
than a film about authentic complex and
ambitious characters it lacks the
originals gritty edge to see me to take
cues from High School Musical and Glee
instead critic Roger Ebert gave the film
two stars writing the new Fame is a sad
reflection of the new Hollywood where
material is sanitized and dumbed down
for a hypothetical teen market that is
way too sophisticated for it 1973
British horror film The Wicker Man
follows devout Christian police sergeant
Neil Howie as he investigates an
isolated island cult he travels to the
island of summer Isle to find a missing
young girl Rowan Morrison who he
believes has been taken to the island
based on the contents of an anonymous
letter how he worries that she's
intended to be a human sacrifice for the
cult but what they have planned for how
he is even more terrified the Nicolas
Cage led 2006 remake of The Wicker Man
couldn't help but fall short of the
eerie expectations set by the original
moments intended to be heroine are
instead so absurd they came across as
genuinely hilarious and the unsettling
atmosphere of the original film is
completely missing
when a horror movie comes off more like
an ill-conceived comedy it's hard to
walk away without feeling like everyone
involved was phoning it in the 2008
American remake of the Japanese film one
missed call has the distinction of being
one of the few films to score a whopping
zero percent on the tomato meter the
original one missed call wasn't exactly
a classic but this just meant there was
a real opportunity for the remake to
outshine the original and it still
completely missed the mark one missed
call just wasn't scary enough for
critics but that lack of Fear Factor
isn't the movie's real problem now the
real problem is that it's just so
unforgivably boring as Common Sense
Media wrote in their review one missed
call suffers from predictable characters
overused conventions of the horror genre
and a plot that never really makes sense
the 1939 comedy film the women featured
an all-female cast and while one of the
main themes of the film is the
characters relationships with men not a
single man is seen throughout with
today's push for more female
representation in movies you would think
that remaking the women would present a
great opportunity for Hollywood
sadly the 2008 remake left much to be
desired it wasn't anywhere near as witty
or charming as the original and the
ensemble cast talent was largely wasted
comparing the film to the 1939 version
critic Linda Barnard wrote for the star
what was then snappy dialogue from meowy
Madam's now placidly flaps lost in
translation from old world to new check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you